when did you become able to be objective
rather than the girl that we enter these
Enterprises with another person rather
than the woman who
realizes that person that you're
engaging with will not get there I think
that I go on that same Journey with
every relationship I enter every
relationship as the girl who's hoping
and who's wishing and then at a certain
point in that relationship you grow into
the woman who realizes um so I wouldn't
say that I got to a point where now I
always enter a relationship fully
realized I definitely don't because I'm
constantly attracting you know
Partnerships and relationships are
really just a place for you to have to
face the shadow of your childhood
traumas and the shadow of um your belief
system about relationships that you
watched in your parents whatever that is
and I have very specific ones based on
my parents so I'm always attracting to
myself either a version of my stepfather
or a version of my mother and then and
what is that um my stepfather was he's
passed on now he was a very um impulsive
and aggressive very like verbally
mentally emotionally abusive and then my
mother who is still with us and I don't
want to drag my mother but my mother I
perceived her to be more passive and
wasn't as protective of me as she should
be and so I think I either will attract
a partner who brings the sort of um
overly masculine the the rage element
and then I become my mother in that
relationship or I attract a partner who
plays the role of my mother and that
awakens a shadow in me as well where I
become very rebellious and um I I resist
and and uh push against the relationship
from that angle um I'm so amazed to hear
are you in therapy yeah I've been in
therapy obviously a long long time oh
the words the key words you're using too
like I have
been someone who entered all of my
relationships um hedonistic and then
incredibly stubborn yeah you know like I
loved the drama I loved the butterflies
I loved the highs and lows The Agony and
the Ecstasy it the greatest addiction of
all time nothing can replace that it's
so hot the endorphins can't be replaced
from a dramatic relationship like that
yeah it's easy to get addicted to that
well then I would respond also to a lot
of the drama like with total Rebellion
as you said and like rage it's like I
would meet fire with bigger fire and
then at some point and this is part of
like the death I think I'm still
mourning and wondering when does the
rebirth kick in of I became passive for
the first time in my life I'm with you
there yeah because I've got kids yeah
and so now this isn't about me anymore
and you're a mom and you have three
incredible children what is it when it
comes to your kids what side of the
woman does that
represent I think with my kids that was
the first cuz when I was young I was
really rebellious and and wild and uh
was always running away to fall in love
with a new love every new co-star every
whatever I was just a free spirit that
way and I was addicted to the to the
falling in love and I think I probably
heard a lot of people in that process
too because a lot of people have really
been in love with me and I did not
respect or honor that and then when I
had kids something happened in me where
because I didn't want to repeat my
childhood it was so important I think
it's a major part of my soul's journey
in this lifetime to not repeat my
parents' pattern with my kids and I was
always very aware of that and so this
selfless person was born when I birthed
my first child yes yeah yes yeah
yes yeah um
and I'm having a a a quintessential aha
moment as Oprah so brilliantly puts him
I'm wondering if part of the death of
that Rebel was not caused by a man but
by my children MH uhhuh yeah I've never
thought of it that way because it's so
obvious to me the shift in my behavior
yeah my prior ities my work
MH thank you for that helpful road that
I can now travel down and explore it's
been completely in the wrong direction
on a one-way Street to Nowhere
[Music]
MH